Yeah.
This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that
provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Well,
go to your mom's house,
Christina,
where brand new studio at the time.
You just said that on the recording.
You want to explain yourself,
you should explain it.
You're very excited about this.
I feel like this is your, your project,
your baby that you've been gestating on.
We're in the early stages of,
uh,
getting a new studio space
for us to expand the show.
Big surprises around the
corner guys. It'll take a
while. It'll take a few months.
Yeah, of course. But then you got
this whole wow thing going on.
Like how dare you,
I'm two weeks from delivering
a human being right now,
just two weeks before a person comes
out of my vagina and it's a miracle.
I'm even sitting here talking to you
right now. No, Gosh. But yeah. So anyways,
we're,
um,
we've been looking at spaces and there'd
be a whole thing and we've been looking
into fart.
Mike's,
which has been a long time coming out
of people need to hear the today would
have been a crazy day for them for you.
You've got a lot of toot toot. Yeah.
I'm serious about the might.
I feel only a lot of our listeners
are serious about wanting one.
About one of them. Yeah. Um,
we got the equipment,
Tom.
Oh wait, that's a mastermind. Go
check out his instrumental playlist.
All streaming platforms,
Spotify,
apple music, De de, m, f,
the motherfucking mastermind.
Oh,
I don't know if he goes by de MF
mastermind or mastermind or, anyways,
anyways, you can always get
your, um, instrumentals or
show inspired songs
submitted here. Just go, uh,
send them to your mom's podcast@gmail.com.
There's no house in that gene. Where are
you going to be doing? Um, standup comedy,
uh,
planning in 2019 tour as we speak.
Those dates will come
shortly for now for 2018. Uh,
just a couple of dates. November
24th, man, Diego, California.
At the House of Blues. December
8th. Do Dork titties. Two shows.
First one sold out. We added a 10 30
show at the Gramercy theater. And also,
I mean, I, you know, I apologize.
I announced Philly a while back and uh,
it just got pushed back. The release
date. By the time this comes out,
the tickets will be on sale.
I believe it's December 7th,
the night before a judo or kitties.
I will be doing Philly at the punchline.
So get those tickets
at Christina P on line.
What about you Jean Jacket? Um, well,
so they moved, you know, the brayer
shows to a new place, a block away,
a bigger room. The capacity went up to
five 50, so they release some tickets.
O M G and they all sold out.
So it's all gone. My Gosh. Uh,
brass balls,
beach Saturday's sold out.
There's still some tickets left
on Friday for us. We added a show.
We added a show in, um, Eugene, correct?
No,
you had a better one for jeans or jeans,
blue jeans, Oregon. October
four, we added a late show,
uh, the late show and boys, boys
seed, Idaho. I like that a lot.
I believe is gone now to Sacramento.
We had a few tickets left.
Fresno Bart Know Bakersfield,
Fort Myers, Florida.
Jack me off bill. And if
Orlando yes, we're all moving.
Augusta did to get those tickets
before they're gasta. Okay.
Uh, Montclair, same thing and fill her up.
Delphia that second show is,
uh,
is getting real close Montclair. Yes. Uh,
and we did of course put a show on sale,
had Pachanga in Temecula,
so all that Tom segura.com/tour.
I say what I'm trying
really hard not to do,
cause I breathe really
heavily when I'm pregnant.
I'm trying not to do what your dad does
into the phone. Like what's the worst
latest thing was when I, when I
finally was like, what? Like I go like,
what the fuck's going on? What are you
doing? He goes, just our breathe. Yeah.
And I go, no, it's not. It's
not just how you breathe. Yeah.
You don't just go,
what do you think's going on?
I mean, something abnormal. You can't just
be like, that's how I read. No it's not.
It's not how you treat labored breathing,
labored breathing.
That's why I breathed that way. Cause
I'm, you know, 37 weeks pregnant. Yeah.
And I shouldn't be this heavy,
but my fat Indian Stepdad who's dead now,
he looked like this all the time
cause he had a lot of hard fat.
What was it you called? Visceral
fat and yeah, and he was always like
to, so it has something to do with
having a big fat belly. I think.
Well maybe it does. I Dunno. He um, uh,
he totally just exude, just goes like,
well I do tell me, I mean that's just how,
oh my God, this just our brain
just harboring, oh my God,
you're going.
Yeah.
That's how you breathe. No, it's not
like you have shortness of breath.
It's not healthy. It's definitely
not a healthy way to breathe. No.
Like it kills me more. He's answered
to it then that he's doing it.
You know what
I mean?
Like when someone is just goes,
that's just how I know it
is not just how you do it.
Cause I'm also around you when you're
not doing that. How is that right? Yeah.
So when is he not doing that? I
don't know. It's just like TV.
It's more like a resting. He
doesn't break read that way. Oh No.
Do you think he's excited? Maybe and
it's like excitement, breath very well.
Could be, but it's not, it's not like
something you should just ignore and go.
That's just his breathing pattern.
It's not
just my way, just how I do this.
Dad just people had all the time.
I go to the doctor. That's just
how Ip, yeah, that's just how I be.
But it's like how we get, he's always
read like how as humans we just get,
we adapt to the bad things.
Instead of being like, Hey,
I should probably go to a doctor,
has no outlet next to my nightstand.
I just can't plug in over here.
Guess I won't charge my phone.
Makes me fucking crazy.
That's his explanation.
Why are you breathing so heavily? Just
how I breathe. It's, but it's not,
you're right. There's something,
there's some neuropathy issues.
Definitely someone neuropathy.
Uh, before I forget guys.
Amazon.
Do you shop there low,
just suggesting that you shopped there
and you might want to look at another
website before you do
get stuck
and you can shop there very well
through their, through their, um,
we are debuting every episode of your
mom's house two hours before they go to
youtube on twitch,
twitch.tv/your mom's
house podcast queen genes.
Is it?
It's queen genes.
The number one queen g is number one
and Dj dad mouth one. Queen genes one.
We both jumped on a little
bit on the stream last right.
And we'll be back again.
Look back and we'll say hello to you guys.
We'll just talk it out.
Draw out a thing.
Now that people can talk to each other
as they watch the show and they can say
things like,
Christina's tits look exceptionally large
today or two we'll keep talking about,
they're like, wow, her stomach
keeps getting beverage.
Is she pregnant? Is she
really pregnant? Yeah.
People keep saying I'm as
fat as Burt and I don't know.
Do you think that my stomach looks as big
as birds? His stomach bigger than mine?
He has. He thinks out of the
bird's fatter than, I mean not fat.
This is in fact this is a child, but,
oh, he looks like you as triplets. Yeah,
he's huge right now. He's really
big, but he knows he's really big.
He's really big. I talked to him.
He does. Yeah. He say just, um,
just when he's just been going
hard. You know, he's been traveling,
touring a lot and uh, he's, uh,
he's still riding the marathon flames.
Oh.
So he still thinks he's burning calories
from running one marathon in April?
Yeah. The answer is yes. And
you're really kind of went
crazy after the marathon. Yeah. It's
been months, months, Bro. I get it.
Shit. Uh, yeah. So he's gonna
he, he just goes, you know him.
It's either hardcore one way or the other.
Yeah. Well, I saw a picture of him,
you showed me on Instagram. It doesn't,
it doesn't look good.
Nothing. None of it looked good. No, no.
Yeah, it doesn't look good. He looks
heavy. It could be the lighting,
but I don't think so. I don't
think so. You know, pictures are,
it's pretty brutal.
Sounds like my dad talking
about his breathing bad
light. It's not a good light.
It's just how I breathe,
how I breathe.
I feel totally normal and natural,
but that is a common dad breath thing,
like with her fat when they're fat,
it's really fat isn't it?
Isn't it just means I guess. I don't
know. I mean my Indian fat Stepdad,
that's why he did that because he,
he was really terrifying to sit next to,
I'm serious.
I've sat next to him when he's
doing that and I go, are you okay?
I'm fine. Terrifying. Have you? You're
fine. He's like, I'm fine. I go here.
You're going like that. He's like, oh, I
feel fine. Like completely dismisses it.
Yeah, no. You know what he does to his,
he'll put his arms around
his body and then come
and you'll see like his chest rise and
fall and the arms too and you're like, oh,
you're really going hard there.
You're really working hard and you're
just sitting here like, I wonder,
has he been for a physical?
Oh yeah, yeah, no, I called
them. I always check on it as a,
as a health and he had some tests run
everything you like past everything was
like flying cars, Pyne, Pyne,
Pyne. Hmm. So maybe it is just my,
we breeds, I don't buy it. I don't buy
it. I'd need to hear a doctor tell me.
It's definitely normal. Well, if
he started breathing like that,
I would hope that you'd run to the
hospital. If I was reading like that,
I would know that is not how I breathe in.
You breathe just sitting here.
Yeah. And it's also, it's not
every phone call and it's not,
every situation is odd.
It's gotta be due to excitement or maybe
some physical activity. He's just done.
We got to pay attention to when
the heavy breathing begins.
I'm going to start paying attention more.
You're really gassy today.
Exceptional.
But you've already taken two
shits too. Yeah. You took one.
You take to Nate came back from Ellis
school. You take a shit. That's it. Oh,
I thought you went upstairs to take
another one. No. Oh, just change shirts.
He farted a lot after your shit,
which is like not normal.
Usually brings that whole
theory and the question.
Well Cause Brown makes the fart slow down.
Yeah.
Well in your case
sometimes it the forts come
out more.
Some days.
God just gives you gifts all day long
and then this could be one of those days.
Yeah. Yup. Interesting. You're ready to
jump in this? Sure, sure, sure, sure.
I got a lot of topics.
Yeah.
Does
your phone
think
don't
go to your mom's house?
Personally I don't think I would be
embarrassed and I'll tell you why I don't
keep saved things on my phone is God
pulling up my search history? Yes.
That's an issue.
But saved items.
I don't keep thinking saved.
Who's saving pornography? I Dunno.
I feel like that's kind of a,
I mean you only,
what you save is you save the horrifying
thing to show your friends. Right.
The jokey stuff. Yeah. The joke you
stuff, the really outrageous stuff,
which everyone knows that you're doing
that just to kind of shock people,
but God knows when you're trying
to shock people. Yeah, he knows.
And do you think he got invented
porn stars got invented porn. Yeah.
He knows when you want to come.
He knows that there's stuff that if
you're going for your common stuff,
you saved the comm stuff. I don't
think so. I don't know. You know,
but I've heard the guys do and I,
they share that the,
they're good clips with each
other. I've heard guys doing
that. Really? Oh No, dude,
you guys are all fucking
nasty shit. I don't, uh, I
don't have the type of friend.
I don't have it. I really
don't. The guy who's like, hey,
I dropped off a lot to this clip. You
might want to jerk off to it too. Um,
yeah. No. Well that doesn't
really happen for me.
I don't have friends that are like,
this is gross.
You want to a man know what
makes you come. But this
made me, it's not like that.
It does seem rather personal.
It, yeah, it does. Pornography.
Now you'd get the penis out,
you'll pull the skin.
A lot of people then there was
circumstances. Yeah. Circumstance this.
So it's very, um, I don't think
I'd be embarrassed either.
I don't w what's on there? Pictures
of my kid. Yeah, some stupid things.
I've written jokes like, oh,
okay, that's not really my auntie.
She's embarrassed of the stuff on her
computer and she's projecting out stuff
that she pulls up when
she wants to. Rajan, Rob,
rob being that person.
Like what is wrong with us?
Like what is wrong with these people?
What was timed? If I could do all that,
that's a lot of time.
A lot of times to yell at strangers.
And here's the way I found out about this
lady. She's got a youtube channel now.
Boy,
she does this shit all the time.
She travels all over the world who
her channel. It gets like, you know,
a hundred views a video.
So I have no idea how she funds this.
She does this or she go crazy trips.
She does these crazy, she talks about,
you know, uh, it's her trips. Yeah.
And then the best is that
she's in Europe right now.
You see everybody who walks by Europeans
are so much more comfortable with this
stuff. They don't guilt, guilt,
trip people for watching silliness.
It's nonsense. It's absolute nonsense.
I mean, this is what she wears that
Amsterdam. Yeah, I think so. Yeah.
Okay.
Even that's an eyelash. Yeah.
Yeah. They just kind of like, oh,
this is a really crazy
person. Littleness. Yeah.
They're really treating her
as such, you know? Yeah.
No,
you don't realize that. That's
just a story. Metaphor. Well,
it's also quite a bummer to think that
you've traveled all the way to Europe in
this beautiful square and the only thing
she's doing is yelling at people for
jerking off. I know.
God put your shit down.
Go put the Bible down and go eat a waffle.
I wonder little beer if you're this crazy.
How do you get through?
Like how do you get through breakfast?
Like Perry,
who crazy to interact in life,
but you're, you know what I mean?
Like you don't know how crazy this is,
but you know how to get on a plane. Yeah.
And you buy a ticket. You can click
on the Internet. You buy a ticket.
You have a passport.
Yeah. How did she do that?
How does she then the God messages
kicks in after that. I don't know.
Or did she have a husband and he's
got a fucking get an ear full of this
nonsense every day. This lady doesn't
have a husband. I don't think so.
It's so weird to me. There's no men
putting up with this nonsense. Elise.
She's got a purpose in life. You
know what I mean? It's her thing.
Then she's traveled from
Tennessee to Amsterdam to be like,
what's on your phone?
At least she left the United States.
A lot of Americans never do. Yeah,
that's true. I'm proud of her.
That's true.
Does
Amsterdam?
Yes,
everyone does.
I'm a nerd.
I said, well, what all those
people are there for you, nerd.
You're a fucking fucking Dork.
That's the leader of the door.
That's why everyone went there in
the nineties when I was in college.
That's like the first destination.
That's when, yeah, no one could get,
we'd go to Amsterdam. You go walk
around the red light districts.
He hookers and stuff. P in the
streets. Yeah, that's fine.
No, she still goes there.
He tests too.
What happens in Amsterdam
not staying in Amsterdam?
or shop?
God,
you know, when I was in, um,
Charlotte, a couple of years in a row,
there's a corner there on what does it
try on street where somebody is up there
doing, not this stuff, but
some similar thing preaching
the corner. It's interesting.
It's so annoying. Childish. Well,
it's childish to think that God is keeping
score cards on people's jerk sessions.
Yeah. And like what are
you masturbating to time?
Is it Hetero or is it weird
how hard you come though?
Like he's grading it. I hope so. I don't
think he's got that kind of time. But no,
it seems like he has more important
things going on. And then again, he is,
God knows everything.
Right.
And we're saying him a gender right now.
Oh.
Oh Shit. He is. God, you know,
I'm sure a lot of people listening right
now who are nodding along. Thank you,
Tom. Thank you. I'm offended.
You know, it's so funny. Every,
every month with our boy and I'm
sorry to assign him a gender,
but I mean look, these people that
are really hung up on this shit,
like you're assigning gender
properties to kids. Like,
I don't know if you've ever
raised a boy or a girl. Why?
That shit's pretty innate.
Like glaring. Yeah.
I'm not forcing trucks into his
hands are forcing dirt on him.
He just gravitates to it naturally.
Yeah. It's pretty innate.
Yeah. He's all dude. And you know, I
tried giving them dolls than like it.
Oh.
I think a lot of it has to do with this
social construct that he's been brought
up.
No.
Do you think marijuana? Marijuana,
how come nerds always call it marijuana?
They're racist. Oh, is that right?
Racist term. Marijuana. Yeah.
What are you talking about?
Uh,
I did this a show where they play this
clip that marijuana is actually racist.
Then the word interest,
you'd be saying cannabis.
Oh, the medical term is cannabis. I see.
I see. Well it's marijuana. A white.
Why is it racist?
Because I don't know.
Yeah, I don't know. Yeah, cause
it was used to, I don't know.
Marijuana.
Why?
Cause it's racist ass.
The term was used to knock on people
of color and their devilish ways. Ooh,
the word itself is an inherently racist,
but it was used by American prohibitionist
to exploit racism and xenophobia.
So by using the m word, oh, right.
Crashing against Mexican immigrants.
Here we go. Let's go on a quick history.
Shall We? Oh Geez. We'd have the American
elite since the 1840 [inaudible].
It was even sold over the counter as
medication to treat insomnia, Migraines,
and rheumatism. But it didn't
become controversial. And
to the early 19 hundreds,
when millions of Mexicans migrated to
the US following the Mexican revolution
with them,
they brought muddy water and their customs
is milking it casually and regular.
Yeah,
I get it. So if you say muddied one
though, you're implying that it's
saying marijuana. Oh, for good.
Because it's racist ass. Oh,
for God's sake. This is
what I did. The podcast.
Okay. Ethan Cline and he la Isla, um,
sounds like a Mexican name.
She Mexican Israeli. Hmm. Um,
but they played this for me. Okay.
And how do they feel about it? Well,
I know how I feel about it.
I feel like this makes a lot of sense
and I'm not down with racism of any form
or any kind. Yeah. And I think
that when people do say the m word,
they are really rubbing it in
the faces of people like me,
people of Latin descent,
people have uh, families that,
that grew up in these areas and that
had been marginalized for centuries.
And so I, yeah, I stood up for this
guy because I'm also fucking stupid.
So
that's just how I feel.
The m word and that's my favorite is
the amp. And you can't say marijuana.
Of course. You could say marijuana.
Unbelievable. You should say marijuana.
And the thing that you should really do
is find this guy and say marijuana to
him all the time. Let him get
upset. My favorite, he's, he's like,
it's not inherently racist.
It's like racist adjacent.
Like once you hear this fucking long
ass convoluted thing, now it's racist.
This is this, this, this is
a perfect example of Christ.
The end of the world. Yeah.
Well, the end of the world,
and this is liberals
who've lost their gardens,
this is far left wing.
Liberals get it in their heads that,
um,
you know, that everything is a problem.
Every language, everything is a problem.
Every look, every indicator,
every day. What's your, you
should meet people and go,
what's your pronoun like when the
nonsense takes over. Yeah. It's, um,
it's,
it's really a liberal thing.
It's the social justice warriors and
far lefties who are just as crazy as the
far righties and the Internet. I'll tell
you the biggest problem I think too,
is that people can search for
something and get this much tiny bit of
information on a huge topic
and now they're fucking
suddenly experts on it. Oh,
but you didn't, he didn't see this video
of this thing. It's like, dude, listen,
it's so silly. Everybody.
So it's out of control. Yup.
Everybody's out of fucking control.
It's absolute nonsense.
Everybody's so fucking sensitive
about shit that doesn't matter.
It doesn't even fucking matter. The main
things we should stop saying marijuana.
I know. That's the biggest problem
in the u s right, idiot man. I know.
He's offended.
My favorite.
I'm really offended when
people say the word marijuana.
I like when you get offended by
something that absolutely nobody,
it doesn't register to anyone. You
know? Like if you're like, um, uh,
you know, you should really be careful
when you say watermelon. It's like, wait,
what? Why? They're like, well, you don't
know the history of watermelons. No,
no one else does either.
Most of us are just trying to keep a
roof over her head and raise our children
and trying to make, not make them
assholes. You know what I mean?
When Armenians first got to this country,
one of the only fruits they consume or
watermelons. So when you say watermelon,
you're really talking about the plight
of the Armenian immigrant. Oh, okay,
well I'm gonna eat some watermelon
now you can go fuck yourself.
And the saddest part,
the scariest part is that if you
say what we're saying right now,
like people will light you up because
people are so fucking irrational now.
A license to be outraged against
people with common sense.
That's the current thing.
It's like just somebody saying
something logical and reasonable.
You can be completely outraged
and be applauded for your
outrage. Right, exactly.
And that's 2018 and it's social
media to a lot of these nut bags.
They congregate on Twitter or whatever
and they all group together and gang up
and it's, I, I again, I don't think in
reality it's a huge majority of people,
but it's fucking idiots like this who
put these videos together and then a
smaller group of idiots who have nothing
going on in their lives on Facebook can
get people think you're outrageous.
If you back talking about process,
somebody got accused of a crime,
uh,
let's wait to see what they have to save
for it. And they're like, no, wait, what?
You don't think that person, you don't
want to hear what they have to say. No,
I know. Because now reality
is whatever you say it is,
there's no such thing as an objective
reality anymore that we all take part in
because everybody's allowed to have
whatever crazy fucking opinion they have.
It's cool, man. Do you
like, listen, it's not okay.
There are certain things that are
fucking empirical evidence. It's true.
The earth is round guys. Sorry.
You know science reason, logic.
Now you just invent your reality.
Marijuana is racist. Guys can't say that.
Those pictures from space
or manufacturing, there's
a huge conspiracy going on.
It's between like every scientist.
I think they're controlling that in acids.
Definitely involved.
Astronauts are involved. Yeah.
Satellites are involved. Russians,
Putin or all together.
Just to make people think the earth is
round because the benefit of that is
that and then
then you can go for a ride on my boat.
So this is um, different. This
girl is coming out of surgery.
Parents.
Uh,
that's a special talent that you can
stick that all the way to the back of your
neck. Don't act like you
haven't been done before.
Just for people listening
and not watching.
This girl came out of surgery and they
gave her a popsicle and she, she goes,
you want to see my special talent?
And then she deep threaded her popsicles.
She said that so sincerely to her mom.
That was fantastic.
I love it. Yeah, you
haven't done it. You slash
get all the way to the back of your neck.
Don't act like you
haven't been done before.
She's right.
Your mom's definitely done that before,
but maybe you're better at
it. That's true. Yeah. Maybe
her, maybe mom's a little.
Do you think your mom does?
Does it? Oh, no, no, no.
I don't think so. She didn't
know what that was? Yeah.
What do you mean she never knew what that
was like when we talked about blowjob?
Like she was like, what?
We're like oral sex. Ah,
because the mangoes peeler. A
peeler. Yeah. What does that mean?
Go like pee in your mouth? No, no.
Like you're going to put where he
pees out of and your mouth, you know?
That's what she thought. She was like, ah
man. I was like, what about looking
at his anus mom? Oh yeah. All right.
That's so off the table
for her. Oh, you and me.
And we should try to bring that
up when they come out. Yeah.
It'd be like if dad really washed
though, like it's really clean. Never.
It would never happen.
Or would you give his cullo kiss
so she'd be so sad.
That's terrible. But yeah, we should
do that. Encourage that. Terrible.
Yeah. Anyways. Um, you know,
it's really neat in our marriage.
You the other day it's,
it's been so like a week ago
now you came home with a salad.
Yeah.
And you normally don't eat in the bedroom.
So I don't know what the box
was doing in our bedroom.
You were very good about
eating in the kitchen, but uh,
you finished your salad and it came in a
clear plastic box and then you had like
a regular fork and you left the salad
box and the fork next to my sink.
We have a his and hers.
And you chose to place it next to where
I brushed my teeth and do stuff and then
I just didn't do anything about it and it
stayed there for like five or six days.
Now is that good? It's
great. What's happening?
What happened with the,
tell me,
walk me through this because
you've never done that.
Brought the salad at home and I went
up to see you. You were upstairs,
you've been resting
and I sat there and I just talked to
you while I ate my salad and when I was
done I just put it in the restroom and
then I went to shower and then I noticed
you put it in there. You were
talking to me eating. Oh, okay. Okay.
So sat up on that chair.
Right. The gray chair and I,
then I went to the bathroom
to shower after the workout.
I put the box there with the fork and
then kind of forgot it there and then I
realized, wow, it's
really like art, you know?
Seeing this beautiful
empty plastic salad box.
Fork. Yeah. Kind of makes you
think, who's been here before? What?
What did they go through?
Right.
What I enjoy too is watching
the leaves turn Brown. Yeah.
Well it was like a live art piece.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Like all the green lettuce,
slowly Wilton and turn Brown and
then black and then all this. Yeah,
the contents inside started to rot.
It was kind of cool. It was very cool.
Very cool. Thanks for putting that
box. Hey, I got to say you're welcome.
You're very welcome.
I enjoyed it quite a bit,
but I finally did take it down.
You disappointed and complained a lot.
You tried to shame me
publicly on Instagram.
You know I did shoot
your typical route cells.
People loved it. They're like, he's
sending you a man message. What's the,
what's the message?
What are we trying to send me?
I don't think there was a message.
It's kind of disrespectful.
It's the way if you let the
dogs run through the house
and then they shit in the
kid's play room, like to show you
like fuck this kid. But I didn't,
wasn't trying to show you anything.
A sign of disrespect.
It was a sign of laziness
and also a obliviousness cause I honestly
would leave there and not notice it at
all. Yeah. I honestly didn't notice it
either for like two days cause I'm really,
I'm really sloppy too. I take
full course so sloppy. Come on.
Do you think I'm messier than who's ma?
Who's the messy champ?
Champ. You're gross. You know your grocer?
Yes. Okay. Here's why
your grosser than me.
You leave food, like the salad box
rotting in the blows plastic salad box.
You Shave your beard, your
back, your balls in sink in your
side,
and then you leave the hair there and
then like to clean up the majority of the
hair. And then he was for days. No,
no, I don't leave a full shaving.
I cleaned that up and there's
hundreds of hairs. Thousands of them.
So little ones are left behind.
They get stuck in the toothpaste cause
you'll spit your toothpaste out. Yeah,
that's part of the artwork too.
Um,
you've hocked a luggy in the
kitchen sink. I remember that. Yeah.
You're pretty good with a shower.
Other than like the Hobo showering where
you slow Snot rockets and you pee all
over me and stuff like that.
I feel like you're, you're,
I'm pretty messy though too.
Like I leave supermoon everywhere.
I drop things and I'll pick
them up, pick them up, clothing.
I'll just leave everywhere. Care. I
can't bend over right now. So just found,
I know this has nothing to do with
right now. You don't pick up your messy.
Tell him I say yeah,
but who's the messy champ?
Hm.
I think you are because in this
completely imbalanced and unfair society,
women are held to a different standard.
So you're messier because you're a woman.
That's true.
Cause I sh I'm supposed to be house proud.
I'm supposed to be more kept,
right? Like, like, yeah. Yeah.
Come on now we'll say you
do have impeccable hygiene.
I do like to keep myself
clean. Very clean person. Yeah.
I brushed my teeth way more
than you. I do, I floss more.
I Have Dj, dad mouth. Uh,
by the way, this is not going to have
to also tag it on another announcement.
Um,
but at this might be the week now.
They moved my hot ones and I didn't know.
So I think I've mentioned
in a previous episode now,
but now it's coming out July 12th.
This shit,
this might even be out,
uh,
after it comes out because where we were
prying to prerecord a bunch before the
baby. Yeah. So I don't
know when this obviously,
so this is either coming out right
before July 12th or a full week after it,
in which case you can tell just how far
ahead of time we're recording things.
Okay. All right. Um,
I like talking about the diarrhea I
had the other night. If you don't mind,
that'd be really great. I mean, okay.
So I was so hungry. I've been not,
I had steak for dinner,
Brussel sprouts and a potato.
An hour later I was starving.
Are you going to look at me and
pay attention to me to talk?
And then I had a thing of
yogurt, blueberries, Muesli,
and then an hour later I had
toast with peanut butter.
What are you doing? But now I'm
pregnant. I'm starving. And then
point out though,
before you get to your messy browns
that for a long time for this pregnancy,
it's the other way you're always
having, you're struggling. Yeah,
it, that's the, that's the fun part.
You, you can't really shit for a lot,
a long time. And then sometimes
just get diarrhea. Anyway,
I started woke up at like three in the
morning and just the fucking flood gates
had open and diarrhea all night.
Don't you hate that?
Of course night diarrhea is just worse
because then you can't sleep and then the
next day or like still feel gross.
It was terrible the whole
next day I was like, ah,
I can't even move
because you didn't sleep.
You know the worst part about
night diarrhea that takes
you into the next day is
that it restricts your coffee. Yeah. Then
I'm fucked up. I can't have my coffee,
I can't have, my body will just
really fucking shut down. If I do,
you can do it,
but it's like smoking with the flu.
It's not a good idea. I used to
do that when I smoked cigarettes.
Stupid.
Where are we?
I would like give myself a day or two
without smoking and then by day three I'm
like, it's fine. Now
will go away eventually.
So I had night diarrhea and then the next
day we went to go see Sacara Sacara or
Sicario sicario too,
which was outstanding. I
loved it. It was so good.
It's so good. It's really
good. Um, has a what?
Josh Brolin.
Benito El Toro.
Really fucking good movie man. It's kind
of, it's good cause it's a stand alone.
Like you don't have to have seen
the first one. No, not at all.
It is a total stand alone. And then
you're kind of watching the Angela,
I want them to make a third one for
sure. Ghana. They left it open. Yeah.
Josh Brolin. Uh, is that
his name? Yeah. Looks Amaze.
Now Emory Brent wasn't in it,
which I'm really upset about
cause I really dig her.
But Bonito del Toro was, I
love him. You've always loved,
love him. Cause he's like a Puerto Rican,
you know, I love my Puerto Rican. Yeah.
I gotta say that he
looked fucking haggard.
He's a little worn.
I mean he was so bloated and fat
that his eyes looked swollen shut.
I looked like he would drink the night
before and show up on set. I mean,
I believe that he's lived hard.
You know,
I believe that for sure. I
love him. I think he's so key,
so great as an actor
and stuff. But man, he,
and it's such a fucking double standard
because if you look at Emily blunt in
the first movie, she weighs 90
pounds. Her skin is flawless.
Yet these leading guys can be total
animals, total fat, fucking pigs.
It's kind of bullshit.
Yeah. He's um, I dunno,
I feel like he's just gone hard. Yeah.
He's just, he's lived hard for a minute.
It shows, it definitely shows. Yeah. Um,
I'm trying to figure out the,
uh,
with this new car. Yo, let me see.
Cause he definitely,
we watched the car,
you'll one the other
day and it definitely,
do you think he looked better or worse
in the first movie? He definitely better.
Yeah. Yeah. And then he's been riding it
hard. Yeah. I think he just parties, man.
I think he drinks it looks like a drinker.
Yeah.
What are you doing? What he was trying
to look at a picture of him. I mean he,
his eyes look really bloated.
Like, like, like sodium.
Yeah.
Believable. How, what's happening?
He always had heavy eyes though
when I kind of liked that about him.
He always looks Kinda,
Kinda, um, rough. Right.
Which is this thing about him
right there. Yeah, it looks great.
He's a fucking great actor. He's
amazed. He's soaked. So talented. Yeah.
Love Him. He's so fucking fun
to watch, man. He's fantastic.
He was great in the movie, but again,
it just makes you wonder like God,
he's fucking serious. Double standards
between men and women in our business.
Like if you look at these fat fucking
animals to work until they're old and,
and just look at fucking Marlon Brando,
that slob.
What did he wait?
At least three bills.
He was a disgusting mess and he was
still starring in movies. Marlon Brando,
let's see what, he looked like a
fucking mess by apocalypse now.
He had to read everything off of
cue cards. He was so out of it.
Yeah, he was at the end there. Yeah.
I mean they still let him work.
Look at him. Look at him. Oof. Yeah.
Yeah. He's real big there. I mean, yeah.
I like to see a female actress that looks
at Shitty. It's still working. No Way.
Oh my God. He looks like shit on a step
and look at him in his youth though.
Hot Tamale. He definitely,
Oh, who's that fight?
Some mother fucker. No, that's him in his
heyday right there. Yeah. Looking good.
Yeah, but he got, he got
enormous. There's Jack. Oh yeah.
Nicholson doesn't look too good, but
he's not working. He's retired basically.
Yeah, he's retired. Brando. God,
he's definitely,
and even my beloved James Gandolfini.
I love Soprano's.
I think I they James got off and he
was such an amazing actor, but fuck,
he looked like hell to, or you were
watching that movie the other day? Yeah,
with he and Julia Louise Dreyfus,
I think it was called enough sad.
It's a cute little movie on iTunes.
It's a little romance and you're looking
at them side by side and you're like,
I think that is similar age and she's
just rail thin trying to fucking hold it
together. And he, he is so
fucking fat in that movie.
Just so fast like this. So it's just the
one that he died right after that. Yeah,
I think he did and he was really big.
And now it's such a bummer.
Yeah. Yeah. I know. It's
really, it's fucking,
um,
it was pretty crazy.
French champagne and then our
favorite and Orson Welles.
He was real
beg at the end. Really fucked up. Yeah.
I was googling
and I found this great
list on rank or dot. Look,
by the way,
he looks like shit.
Oh my God. Oh my God.
Like this whale. Fuck.
And they let them work. These assholes
work until they dropped dead. Like really?
Yeah. No, that's true. Really.
Yeah. So here's your
a, I pulled it up also.
Yeah. Read the, read the title of
list, which is my favorite thing ever.
It's called the most
successful obese Americans.
Really Nice list to be a part of.
Could you imagine? It'd be really
your PR guys like, Hey, you made this
list on the first sentence it says,
the most successful obese Americans
include men and women who,
despite being overweight,
have found mainstream
such a shit list to be.
Everyone wants to be on lists and then
you get this, you're like, what the fuck?
Why are some successful
fat people who are sorry?
Who are some successes for some being
obese has caused the public to question if
they were fit for their
individual professions.
Athletes like John Daly and
bay route, Blah Blah, blah.
Obviously pundits of trash in New York,
New Jersey,
Governor Chris Christie for his weight.
Um,
sadly for a few of
these obese celebrities,
they're overindulgence and
created contributed to their
death. Well that's, yeah,
of course.
Hey, by the way, I'm not
shitting on people for being fat.
I'm just saying like if you're a lead
actor and film and you're supposed to be a
sex symbol and you're not a character
actor and the fucking ridiculousness of
this double standard.
Like Marlon Brando got to look like that
and when all and work and [inaudible]
kinda barely hanging in there.
Geez, come on. He doesn't
look clean and look good.
He doesn't like Dunlin good look like,
like a Orson Welles or Marlon Brando.
You say he's on his way. He's another
few. Another sicario three. Yeah.
We'll see what it looks like by the third
is stolen. Oh my God. This list though,
I mean right off the bat,
I'll tell you.
I know they have Steven bomber
as number one. Who's this guy?
So he used to be fat. No, I
know. I'm saying I've seen
him in person. He's whatever,
like 20 pounds overweight.
He's big deal.
He was the CEO of Microsoft
after Bill Gates. Okay. Um,
and that he owns the clippers now. It's
crazy to put him on know, be successful.
He's not, he's totally normal.
Dick Cheney Cheney. I mean, again,
he's probably,
he's overweight,
but to be like you did it
despite how enormous you are.
He's like old guy fat and he's
nice. He's a normal guy. Fat. Uh,
Kevin James, James, Super Fat,
Super Fat. Come on, do Kevin James.
Super, super fat dude.
Watch king of Queens.
Maybe not in this photo.
Watch king of Queens next to Leah Remini.
He looks like a fucking porpoise. I mean
the guy is, how fast do you think he's,
not that you're saying super fed thinking
were saying, look, I'm telling you,
watch old king of Queens when
he's wearing like as ups alpha.
What about right now? I
don't know. Right now.
I think he slimmed down since that I'm
talking like I would say when King of
crunk Queens was at its height,
he was a real whale. I mean,
and he was wearing that outfit
and his legs are Chunky.
We Kevin Smith fucking slimmed down.
He looks crazy to call him.
Super Fly was no they got,
yeah.
When he was doing king and gains.
I'm saying you,
the term you're using is not correct.
Well what super was super fabulous.
Super Fat because, but I'm saying he
can't throw him in that cat also. Okay.
All right. So our scale is a little
different. I see what you're saying. Yeah.
You're describing the way you're
talking about is someone like, dude,
that's super fast. So Ralphie super
fat is what you're saying. Okay.
How would you describe them?
Do you not think Ralphie? Okay,
we need to create a scale here
cause you never want to say scale
super fat is Ralphie and
then one step under his Bert,
is that what you're thinking?
Bert Burton.
Ralphie are kind of neck and neck close.
Okay.
Trying to find oh good on that one. And
they look Super Bay there. They will may,
maybe we have different
standards for what super fat is.
It's not like this is a specialist just
came out. No, that's different. That's,
that's because he lost weight
motherfucker. I'm trying
to say this is right now.
Right now. Right now. Right
now. Right now. 30 pounds
overweight. Now he looks great.
He looks great. But I'm saying it the
height of the king of Queens. I know,
but that's still like,
but it's not face.
It's not fucking,
you cannot say that.
This is anything like Ralphie fat.
No fat. No, of course not. No,
I agree with you. No, I agree with
you. I mean, looking at their Alexa,
Leah remeny is that layer. She's
cute. They're cute together.
I love Kevin James by the way. I
think he's super cute. I liked him.
Have these super cute and super fast.
I like Pesky.
I like huskier guy,
the fat pack.
And that's his brother who's
hilarious too. Yeah. Yeah.
And he said funny. Anyways,
he lost a bunch of weight.
But you watched those king of
Queens. I know. Oof. All right.
I mean I watch, yeah,
you got to kind of thick.
But the camera also ads. Of course.
I still think he's that bad.
It's good now. He does now I, yeah. Okay.
Kathy Bates, there you go. There's a
lady or lady finally and she's great,
but she's always been the
acceptable, unattractive. Why
she acts so town. She's guy
talented. So we get her a pass
is what Hollywood is thinking.
Yeah. If you're really good,
they don't care what you think.
Your guy be exception. Yeah.
Ah Shit. I read that. I read
the frank where like how they,
they use actually the respectful photo.
They used a 60 year old photo.
Cute.
She's big as fuck shit.
You do yourself a favor and Google Aretha
Franklin tits right now and there's,
I mean those milkers are just
junk.
I'm in lost a bunch of weight now.
This is actually a,
a post weight loss photo now. He
was pretty fat. He was huge. Huge.
So that I would say make sense.
Not Super Fat, no fat burn fat,
but fat.
He think he was fatter than Bert at
its fattest or Burt's fatter than John
Goodman and Burt's
always been fatter than,
than then John Goodman and Kevin James
was not as fat as John as fattest.
Good point. Okay. And by
the way, uh, oof. Rosie,
Rosie O'donnell, she's
always been just big. Yeah.
But I feel like she carries it.
I don't think she would look normal brain.
Who fucks this guy? Harold Hamm. Hmm.
American entrepreneur.
Entrepreneur. Yeah. Gas Business.
Pioneering in the development
of the large, I can't read
it. State of resources.
I don't know. I guess I'm on, he's worth
the nine point $3 billion. Dang homie.
Which decreased from 18 point
$7 billion so much. My God.
Uh, Charles Barkley. I mean,
it's always been a thing for child like
the Charles Barkley is that he's been
overweight,
but again,
he's like fat for a ridiculously
talented pro athlete.
He's not like, you know, well,
don't you think pro athletes get a pass
because they've been in such incredible
shape for the majority of their law.
He was always Chunky,
even though even as an active
player and he was, you know,
it was thought of like the critique was
that it was a basically a little bit of
a, a lack of discipline. Oh,
you know, that he was just
like indulging, he was like,
I still fucked people up, so who gives
a shit? Um, and then he definitely,
he ballooned at one point.
Like he really ballooned after retiring,
which is also kind of normal
because you're not exactly sure. Um,
so he's always had like a little
bit of a weight thing, but I mean,
I could see why people would call him
fat, but again, successful, obese,
successful in such a
ridiculous Kirstie Alley.
She's always fluctuated as lecturer.
Oprah.
I mean technically maybe,
but she's always, you know,
weight's always been this thing
with her too, up and down.
I wouldn't say obese Al Roker and
he was super fat at one point.
He was fat. He did the, he did. He's
got duct that weird neck and head now.
Yeah. When they get super skinny, like
200 pounds or something, you know,
it's harsh. Yeah.
Roseanne. She got skinny.
Does she do bypass? I don't know, but
she lost a bunch of what it did. Yeah.
Yeah. He's staring Christy super. I think
he had botched surgery. Is that right?
I think so. Damn. So did that one. Um,
there's a football coach that had
botched, botched a bypass. You can die,
you know during that. Yeah. That's pretty
risky. Ruben's stuttered, so we're fault.
Who's this guy? I Kabaka Botarro. You
don't know who that is? Big Sumo Guy.
He's fat and he's always been
fine. Michael Moore. Michael
Moore? I don't think so.
Did he?
I think he got skinny,
so really I follow him on Instagram.
Let's see.
Okay.
Michael Moore, I think he was going
through a skinny phase or something.
He tried.
Did we lose weight?
I don't know how he did.
I thought he went through a skinny face.
I want to say it looks
like he's transitioning.
I see him on our TLC show
this week, man. Coming.
A woman is going on.
Yeah, they get softer.
They get 2000 chalky.
All
rush.
Limbaugh's definitely fat.
I feel like I could definitely
make it to this list,
but I did a few more specials.
Al Gore.
He can't be on, he's not obese. No,
that guy looks super fat. John Daly.
Drew Carey lost it all. He did.
This is a silly list at this point.
We're just getting out there. This is
bullshit. Sumo wrestlers. Carnie Wilson,
remember she was one of the fat Wilson
Phillips. Who's this fucking guy?
Yeah. Okay. This list is
absurd at this point. Yeah,
but I'm with you that in
the movie business where
this is the moneymaker guys,
get a lot of guys get a pass.
Well then again,
you look at some dudes like
your friend Mark Wahlberg,
who's a lead actor and he
stars and everything and he
looks at amazing crazy and
you're like,
that sets a fucking movie star Dude.
Well that's the standard standard you
should said is if you're like you're the
lead of the movie. Yeah, look
good. You got to look good.
And who are like the people like
him, the Rock, Ryan Gosling,
he looks at maze and even in comedy,
you know,
you look at starring
in movies all the time.
Kevin Hart is like in crazy good shape.
That's so true. What about that dude?
What am I fucking thinking?
I'm cruise is still in crazy good shape.
Cruise looks amazing for his age. Fifties
or something to that guy. Never ages.
Yup. Um, oh Bradley Cooper. Yeah.
That guy is in fantastic shape.
He just looks comedic actor.
He doesn't look like Bradley Cooper.
He does a hangover and all that stuff,
but he's just like a
movie star. Yeah. He um,
he just looked like normal.
Good.
Like he doesn't look like
Mark Walberg shape. Right.
He just looks to fit and health.
It is Mark Walberg Jesus Christ.
But he's just like, like he's not
eyes, obviously not overweight.
He doesn't look like he's crazy yoked.
He just looks healthy. It looks good.
He looks like the hot dad at preschool.
Yeah.
When driver kid off
and you're like the day
everybody's like, day. I would by
the way, 100% beyond that list.
Now that I think about it, if,
if I was more successful them,
if I was more successful, they
would definitely be like, ah,
there's a fat Netflix guy
who despite his weight,
I'm sure despite his morbid obesity,
Thompson Sigora prevails. Yeah,
that's really crazy. I
think I would be to, uh, um,
hey, mommy's really nice. Thank you.
So I hope all as well listening to the
podcast about the guy's friend using
subtitles preemptively
laughing at the jokes.
I do agree for the most part that it's
a bad move to have those on if you don't
have any hearing problems.
I however do agree with
keeping subtitles on. Oh,
I keep them on because I can't hear
it from one of my ear pussy and other
airports. He hears just fine.
It's just what he wrote.
But it's also because sometimes it's
easier to comprehend with a comedian is
saying when you read the text
in case you miss something.
I don't always look at the
texts when watching standup.
It's also a case of add or I won't have
patients to hear what the comedian will
say. So I'll read the text on the
screen, wait for the delivery,
and then I will laugh.
It's Kinda like what I was my theory,
which was having anxiety about the
moment of wait. Yep, Yep, Yep, Yep.
It all comes down to a
matter of preference. Anyway,
that's my answer to the question
about having subtitles on love.
You Keith Jeans High and tight of
the baby comes out of maize. Chris,
thanks Chris. Um, whatever your
ear, Pussy your pussy. So Steve,
I feel like that's something
that was said. Your Pussy. Yeah,
I feel like it was said
dog con. Yeah, I dunno.
I definitely feel like,
um, that was mentioned. Um,
yeah, so subtitles, let's see.
There's more subtitles here.
Um,
what this person says.
I mean,
look,
I'm watching a Danish show right now on
Netflix called Rita and I fucking hate
it because you just know you're
missing out so much on, on, you know,
you don't speak the language visitor.
I know it's a different thing,
but reading dialogue is significantly
different than just being able to hear,
oh yeah,
I hate it.
Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Um, so there's,
there's more here for this.
Um,
somebody wrote in for the youtube
subtitles. We didn't realize this.
This will either help the subtitles are
for lunatics argument or the home here.
Now confusion. Here's an email. Uh,
I don't think I didn't
think about it until today,
but I put subtitles on your
recent Youtube podcast.
I think we have the answer for our
perverted piss on me. Beat me champ. No,
she doesn't translate perfectly,
but you'll see,
I guess there's subtitles provided on
youtube videos like this fucking shit. Uh,
but it says home here. Home.
Yeah. Question here. Now.
Attached to a screenshot. Um, anyway,
love the show. I also enjoy shouting
for stroke gang at mini golf. Steph.
So look at this right here.
This is the subtitles.
Look how happy Natasha looks to be. Fuck
me. Piss. Somebody beat me at home. Yeah.
Now, yeah, at home.
I'm home here now to further the point
that what is being said is clearly,
clearly home here now at home.
Now it says at home,
Ya know, we got this email. Hey,
hey there. Todd and Christine.
Initially, I didn't think why IMH
mustached Casanova was saying,
I'm home here now.
I thought he was saying how a man out,
as many listeners have
sworn that he is saying,
but I still wasn't totally convinced
and realizing that the problem with the
audio is that it is too
open to interpretation.
I instead played the video and
carefully watched his disgusting mouth.
Then multiple times at half speed there
you can clearly see his mouth open for
the first word.
His lips come together and then open
again before saying the second word.
This is solid evidence that his first
word is I'm now for the second word.
You'll notice that his mouth forms
a circle, which we already knew.
Then his lips immediately come out
together again, just as they did before.
Clear evidence. The second word
is home. Wow. For the third word,
the important thing to take into
account his, his east coast accent.
There's no hard are instead is
replaced with an a or your sound.
So here becomes here or here.
Right?
Because of his intoxication from being
on whatever's on and also because of his,
a sheer, an immense excitement at all. The
homeless convict caught coming his way,
his words slurred together.
So home here becomes home with a
soft why sound homea like home?
Yeah, home. Yeah. Now
the last word is of no,
but debate and is obviously by all
accounts now there you have it.
This lyrical gangster, this poet, this
man of intrigue and mystery is saying,
I'm home here now I'm home. You
know like that. Yours in jeans,
Graham,
here is a video of it
being played in slow Mo.
Oh Shit.
Yeah, my homie are now.
Wow. That was indisputable.
I mean, I don't know what some
of these people are hearing,
but he's definitely,
I'm home here now, mom. Yeah.
Now it also speaks to the whole
message of come over and over.
I'm here. Try this out, do
whatever you want to me.
I'm hoping I gave you my address. 2195
that's right. I'm a home here now.
Contextual evidence supports
this and also the accent,
which is really interesting that this
person points out I'm home. He on now. He,
he won't say his r's hard.
Very interesting.
It's very interesting when a
compelling, compelling, yeah.
This presale went nuts
here for the new one. I,
this is absolutely one of my top favorite.
Your mom's house shirts. I just, I love
everything about this design. I love it.
I just love this. I, God bless
whoever drew this one sketch,
Chris drew this what?
All the different,
all the different possibilities
of what he's saying.
Although I've obviously on team home
here now there's homie out homie on out.
Hold me down. How a man out home right
now hold me out. Hold a man down,
own me in and out.
Hollow me out.
Everything that people think
they're hearing is on that shirt.
It's really great and the
drawing is just spectacular.
Go to merge method.com/tom to grow or
you go to [inaudible] dot com just click
on the store. It looks terrible
too, and that drives wrong. Yeah.
There's never a point where he looks good,
which is wonderful. It's just so fun.
Would not be the star of a movie.
Maybe he would actually. Oh right.
Benito del Toro's looking a little home,
man. I'm here right now. The rough.
I've been an issue and I'm like, good. Um,
somebody wants to know some
advice on a knife sharpening.
Rah Rah Rah. It sounds like your domain,
bro. I know. Let's see what he has to say.
Hey Jean, this is Kevin from
Montauk. Todd and Christine.
As someone who was not circumstances,
I have quite a sensitive helmet,
so I've been trying to
desensitize my glands penis.
Despite my commitment, however,
the review, the results
have yet to materialize.
I've been rubbing and rubbing and
rubbing 50 times left right forward,
back and down everyday sharpening the
knife, but the results are very slow.
If anything,
it's way worser than before.
I'm still reaching totality
and only four stroke.
Although my brother suggested
I try to lay off the meth.
Since I have no neuropathy, I'm starting
to consider alternatives at this stage,
such as sandpaper,
wishful thinking,
changing my pronoun controlled
chemical burns or becoming a hermit,
not which route to take. Hoping
you can offer insight. Anyway,
I just felt I needed to share.
Maybe this information can help
other dog cons with similar issues.
Keep up the good work and fuck
me in my ass, man. Kevin. Wow.
That's a real nice message. Cousin.
Wonderful letter. Yeah. That's a
really good way of putting things,
um, known rapid the issues. Yeah.
So I dunno. Um, how do you,
how do you desensitize the glans penis?
I was asking,
it seems like he's already, he's doing
what, what the great doctor advised.
Right. Which is you, you
have to work, you know,
you have to rub, rub, rub all the time.
Me saying he's doing that,
it's making it even more sense.
I don't understand that. I mean in my
experience, obviously you're usually more,
you know,
trigger happy if you haven't had
those soft touches in a while,
you know, it makes sense because
you're not yeah. Sensitive. Right.
But then the more you do it more,
yeah.
You are more sensitive. Right. Cause you
haven't touched it though. Right. Right.
But maybe it's also you need,
you need a lady friend or a guy friend,
I don't know what you're into and
um, someone to, to work with on it.
You know,
I think alone it's different because you
can be in control of yourself alone and
then you're with somebody else.
Oh, you bus real quick. So he needs
someone else to help him rub, rub, rub.
So, and then make it not such
a shock, you know, not such a,
a surprise to your
system. Like, oh my God,
there's somebody else
touching it right now.
Oh, right, sure. I, you
know, hey, this is your,
I had a friend in college who told me
that he was so excited that he was with
this girl and they went back to his
place and she just touched his leg and he
came and
oh no. He was like, ah,
I know. I was like, no,
cause I've had a definitely
had like fucking eight seconds,
you know, where you're
like, here we go. Ah.
But I never had someone
touch my leg and it happened.
No. That's the sad part about being a
guy that's gotta be really tough. Yeah.
Because once you blow your, your stuff,
then you got to wait to regroup. Yeah.
You know? Yeah. It's trying to build up
your supply. That's the thing though.
I remember talking to,
I talk to you about this one.
I talked to Rocco about it that
time when he came to the show. Yeah.
What did he say? He said, uh, he's
like, you just need to work a lot.
He talks about like professional,
he's talking about the shooting films.
I was like,
well how do you control your,
uh, you know your your shot? And he's
like, oh, he's nothing. And I go,
yeah, but how, how does somebody
start? He goes, you work 30 days,
you'll have complete control.
So he was saying like, well,
I thought it made sense too because
if you're talking about, you know,
let's say I don't have sex for two
weeks, right. And then, you know,
I've been traveling, I come home. Yeah,
that's not going to be a long one.
But then if you have sex
four times that week,
by the fourth time you don't fit. You're
not that sensitive. It makes sense.
It does make sense. But this guy's
writing, he's, he's doing his,
his training and he said
it's still not working,
cause I don't know how to advise them.
But here's what I'm thinking.
Is He training rob rob to the point
of big docking or he's just rub,
rub rubbing without any,
any, uh, circumstances? Well,
master circumstances, um, you know,
lesson is that you're
supposed to 50, 50, 50,
50,
50 with not without [inaudible].
That's where I think the logic might be
flawed with the rubber up guy is that
maybe if he big ox so much,
maybe that'll help build his
tolerance built the uh, you know,
cause if you're constantly Bogar king,
doesn't that help?
Like what were you doing was
saying? Yeah, but you don't want to,
but God all the time you want to,
what you need to do is rub.
And then if you feel it happening before
you want to, you pull back. I don't know.
Listen, this is who you're learning this.
No, you pull back. You don't go like, oh,
it's stroked number 15. And you feel
it go, you pull, you stop. Right.
So that you learn to have more control
over it. It's gotta be rough though.
This guy's checking it off a
lot. Yeah, it's neat topic.
Hope you learn to come when
you want to come serve.
God's not watching you though. Yeah.
Showing what's on your fucking phone.
Go to hell in a minute.
You think this is funny or no?
Nope.
Already now
a man on a swing.
He's standing growl.
I don't like it already. Pretty
cool. Look at that. He's doing
whoa.
Huge swing.
Yeah.
Is that my tribe? It sounds similar.
It does sound kind of similar. Right?
So he went
here.
Okay.
Yeah. I don't this one. This
is why he's going to fly.
Fuck. And then he just
went head first into that.
Good Dude. I think he's all right
though. I think he's all right.
That was a big flip though.
It's a lot of them
funny or no? Nope. Don't think so. No,
I don't like people getting hurt jeans,
but I mean he's not hurt.
How do you know that?
Is there a followup video?
It shows him walking around and talking.
Yeah. Oh, where is it? Let's see.
They
try and get this message
back from this person,
that person. Well, we talked
a little bit a week or so ago.
A couple of weeks ago about certain guy,
we found his video and then he saw
that we played as video and now he has
something to say then
in long neck, gay, um,
under this much snap bronchus that
Tom just mean like a few days ago.
And I'm calling in La fucking
in there thought, well,
she's shit about me.
I don't get called out.
I made fun of him saying out of your mind,
first of all,
this is the respectful
thing. Oh, is it? Well, yeah,
he's not going to call it rose to men.
He's really scared.
That's the more fucking
names. Oh Shit. See,
I mean daddy around day.
Yeah.
You know this better my neck like that.
You put some respect on my neck piece.
So daddy wrong neck because of
shit. The side, he starts with Shit.
So I hit him up yesterday.
Yeah.
And um,
we had some conversation
going on Instagram and I said,
you know,
I don't think I could handle these things.
You got to find an appropriate opponent.
You know,
I don't really think I'm the guy
to, uh, to fight him, you know?
I just don't think that would be,
well, you're a little
older. Yeah, I'm okay.
Geographically maybe wouldn't work out.
Yeah. This kid's not in California.
He's in Flint, Michigan. How? Okay.
Anyways, he's on Instagram
and he posted, I,
I immediately thought when he was
challenging me to a find it go,
don't think it's an appropriate fight.
What about him and crazy look so and so.
I,
I suggested that and he's like,
I got to check him out. He's
like, I'm gonna check them out.
And then he put this on
Instagram goes cigarette Tom,
I'm going to kick crazy lokes ass.
Oh Shit.
I got hands faster than Mike Tyson
share this to let crazy looks. No,
I'm not fucking around.
I also want to join your podcast on a
call so I can say a little something to
him. Okay. And then is
it Hashtag [inaudible]
I'm not knocking around
and he made this thing,
uh,
damn long net versus crazy. Lokes
he's really, he's ready for it.
Well that would be quite an interesting
match between those two. Absolutely. Yeah.
So his name is Davy gravy. That's what
it says. Is that his Instagram name?
No, Instagram. He's damn long
neck. Damn. Damn long neck. Yeah.
Okay. So I hit him up. I was
like, dude, call in, you know,
but I haven't heard back.
Maybe next episode we'll have an exclusive
with damn long neck and crazy looks.
Maybe there will be some
kind of confrontation plant.
I really hope we can get crazy
looks and long neck to get it down.
We've really silly a crazy lopes.
If you're out there, you know,
it would be great to have you to
send a message to long neck about
fighting. I mean, here's the thing.
I Dunno if long neck knows that crazy.
Lokes is in the gym all the time. Oh,
Robin training. Yeah. And he's training
a lot. I see them and we sparring,
hitting the bag.
I mean,
so I saw long next hand speed
and that's no joke. But no.
But as far as fight experience,
I don't know.
I mean crazy looks is always at the gym.
While it looks like a long neck here.
Trains bare knuckled. That's
true. Totally different fights,
street,
totally different style of fighting.
It looks like we got to see what's going
on with these two. So, uh, I'm a big,
big fan of both guys. I can't believe
you're resurrecting crazy low. I know.
Well I never thought I never saw
it that that would happen. We,
we want crazy legs back.
Put some respect on my name.
He said put some respect on my neck.
He did really cool. Really funny.
Oh Man.
Well let's see what happens
with some respect on my name.
Yeah.
And he said he called our
podcast a broadcast broadcast.
So now we have a podcast and a broadcast.
Close enough.
That's really good.
So very excited at the potential
of a live fight between these two.
I'm excited to hear back from crazy lokes.
It's been a long time.
I want to see if he's still
rapping and training like that.
He's not doing all those things,
doing his thing, stuff like that,
stuff like that.
This was going to blow your mind.
Look who is here again doing this thing.
Okay.
Not Crazy legs.
You noticed it.
You noticed that your name's Keegan
sticking into sticking in a sticky note.
Sticky in stay United State.
You noticed that United States United
sticking in that he's back. I love this.
Where is he? He's a, he's an a.
Looks like it's that Coachella.
He says
he's indoors this time.
Last teeth is what it seems like.
Yeah, he's got less. He's got one, two,
three right now. He's not
in the sun, which is great.
He needs to be out of the sun. Yeah,
glad he took shade. He took shelter,
man. Close enough. I like it. A
whole new outfit. Whole new look.
Really exciting.
I didn't know he had another part
to this on has just come God,
it's a little sun damage. Don't waste. It
has to stand there and then you can go and
stay there.
I love it.
I love,
this is so exciting.
The file says Christina's
dad is the new hot sensation.
He's touring all over the world now.
That's your dad. Is that where you ended
up? I did here. He moved to the desert,
got married to some Vietnamese lady,
and now they're in the desert.
It could be my dad. I don't
know. I haven't seen him in
awhile. It's been awhile.
I know. Who knows. They
stay
United States United.
Such good work talent.
You know what I got?
I bring it up. I just,
I want everybody to know I'm
super proud of you, Tom. Yeah. Uh,
you reached gold medallion
status it Starbucks. Yeah.
Medallian what are you now?
I Dunno. I was forever. I was wanting,
I'm, you know, like an old person.
So I'm resistant to certain changes and
everybody jumping on the thing and I did
not get that APP for a long time,
which is crazy.
I'd kept telling you that way you
can preorder the drink you go in.
It's just how I breathe.
So I just didn't want anything to do
with it. I hear Ya. I finally did it.
And,
and so for those who don't know,
Starbucks has an APP.
You just prepay and then you can order
your drink in advance of you going to the
Starbucks and it's there
waiting and you just
pardon? Oh God, I don't
know what held me back.
You're now, you're in, you're in it
now. Mobile order for sure. Yeah. Yeah.
Then they were like, congratulations.
You hit this status. I don't
know what that means. Well,
what's but what's your status?
I don't know.
It just said like gold and then something
else came in and I just do you get
special perks? That's what I don't
know. Like when you go assuming, no.
Here's the thing that they know me so
well at the one that I like to go to. No,
for the mobile order. They're now
doing my splash, even though I don't,
they know the splash splash.
Exactly how much the splash is
and they're doing it even
though it's not on the order.
There's Tom's order and being
like, oh, he likes to splash.
What an exceptional Starbucks location.
I know they're the best. They're the,
you know, I will say, because we'd
go to the, there's a couple places.
Oh, sip of what water. I'm
sorry. Hold on a second. Yeah.
You're drinking brown liquid and
you're wet. I'm thirsty for water now.
Oh, and what did you just do? Reach
for water. No, you didn't reach her.
You just asked if you could
have a sip of water. My right.
I like you to specifically say that
right now for the listen because I have
water on the table. Jesus Christ.
But let the record show Yana,
Mr Segura who claims
to be the water champ,
did not have water at his desk today
at work. And I did. And he just,
he's drinking mine right
now and he's so thirsty.
You're parched cause you don't
drink enough water. It's obvious.
It's a stupid argument. No, it's
not a stupid argument. So anyways,
yeah, we've been to a few
in the neighborhood and they
are like the Dream Team.
Starbucks. It's like, you're
like norm from cheers.
You walk in and they're
like, Tom, hey, you're here.
Welcome. We've got your drink.
It's amaze. Really crazy. They're
super friendly and they do the,
they do a great job.
So shout out to our local,
you know, branch. Good job
guys. Queef or fart too.
My main mommies and the deans of jeans,
my wife Christina and I had been
debating this topic for five years now.
I know that you two have the insight,
knowledge and mental fortitude
to resolve this issue.
When having anal sex, air gets pushed
into the brown barrel and is expelled.
I don't have anal.
The question is,
is this escaping air a fart or a Queef?
Wow. It's definitely a
queef. This person goes on.
I am firmly in the Queef camp because
just like a queef air is being pushed into
the hole during the act of penetration,
it's not naturally generated within the
body like the gas that composes of a
fart.
My wife backs Brown,
claiming this escaping area is in fact
a fart based solely on the fact that is
leaving.
The butthole is my belief that a fart is
born from within and the Queef is made.
If you trace a queef back far
enough to its point of origin,
you will find that the
air came from the outside.
A fundamentally different
story than that of the Fart.
We come to you with humble hearts,
assured that only youtube can create
the intellectual discourse needed to
resolve this issue and we will
fully respect your final decision.
Uh, save our marriage respectfully.
Edward, they're really in peril.
We are the fact that this married
couple is having sex in there.
How you say his wild?
Um, it's like a regular,
it's wild. I think married,
regular anal is kind of wild. Yeah.
I guess I don't know why we don't do, I
don't do anal holes. It's probably why.
My opinion is that it's kind of wild,
but if I liked it I would probably
request it. That's true. Jam. Yeah,
that's true.
Now Yana allow me to present my case.
Well, I love me. I'm telling you, I
even as I was beginning to read this,
I was immediately team queef because what
do you mean team? Please clarify. Well,
I mean it's a quiff.
He's right.
The thrust is creating an air pocket.
Air is being pushed into her
butthole and then is coming out
as a queef. It's air that
wasn't generated from within.
It's from the movement.
It's a queef. Yeah.
I'm going to have to differ in opinion
here and why by definition a Queef is a
pussy fought.
Now the air you're describing coming
from the woman's anus is actually queef
like in nature. However,
is not a queef. Why?
Because a Queef by
definition is a pussy fat,
therefore coming out of the
pussy. Yeah. But this is a,
this is a different location, Yada.
This is simply a different location.
It is a different location and I
respect that logic, but it's still,
it's an anal queef it's air.
It's anal.
Queef it is a Queef like scenario
coming out of an anus. Yeah.
Now the Queef is by definition a pussy.
Fuck.
So if we're going to change
definitions here, this is absurd.
The definition is a pussy fart.
But it's a anus fart.
Correct.
But it's not a fart fart.
It doesn't necessarily matter.
It does matter.
It does matter when it comes out of a
butthole. I'm not saying it's a fart. Now,
here's the real definition we go.
We have to think about here.
It's not exactly a Fart, but it's not
exactly a queef because like I said,
by definition,
queefs come out of vaginas.
It's kind of a hybrid of the two.
I'm going to say it's like a, uh,
Corfe a Corfe. Well,
what is, what is a, uh,
uh, an asshole? Queef it's an asshole.
Queef but it's not a proper queef.
It's not the same.
You can't start calling anal queefs.
It's an anal queef.
But it is not a vaginal queef. It's
not. It's definitely your queef.
And it's not a pure fart. It's not a pure
foreign, it's not a pure fork. It's not.
It's an anal queef which is
different than a traditional Queef,
you know? No, I, I'm
sorry, but I, I'm a purist.
I stand by my definition that
a Queef is a pussy fart. I see.
That's got to come out of a pussy.
Well,
I mean, do you even care?
I do. F A. R. T. Yeah. So,
but you think it is still considered a
queef? I do think it's an anal queef.
Queef is not necessarily by
definition of Pussy Fart.
A queef is about the idea that
it's thrust generated air.
Correct scapes.
Crap.
That that thrust and that air
can come from two sources,
multiple sources.
The thrust can be from anything.
The escape of air can be from
any, a whole, any hole. Now see,
that's what we got to go to his admin.
Is it in Miriam Webster?
Can we look up wave?
I think that that would
decide this once and for all.
Let's look at a proper definition
of what a Queef is. Um,
it says the sound is somewhat
comparable flatulents
to flatulence from the anus but does not
involve waste gases and thus often does
not have a specific odor associated
slang terms for vaginal flagyl.
Lynch include Vaart, Queef, n Fanny fart
vaginal and that there,
your honor is the hook vaginal flatulent.
You're going to have to be a purist here.
I'm clearly a purist.
You're going to be a little looser
on your interpretation here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Hmm.
But if I had to argue in court,
I'm going to stick to the
definition of vaginal,
a flashlight. But then
how do you, how do you,
you are also on board with the
fact that this is not a waste gas,
you know,
escaping,
right? Correct. The difference
here is that it's not a pure fart.
We're going to give it its
own name. It is a, uh, uh,
anal, an anal Queef, which is
different than a traditional queef.
It's like a sub category.
I got you have a pure Queef
uh, by the way, we have another, uh,
subtitler weighing in here. Okay.
You just want to let throw on my,
on my own 2 cents on the proverbial poop
pile of opinions regarding the issue of
watching standup specials
with the subtitles on it.
I am a transcriptionist and the company
I work for also does closed captioning,
so I'm very familiar with how they do it.
The guidelines of the company sets for
the projects we work with require us to
change slang to grammatically
correct language. For example,
Gada has to change to got to
know I'm gonna is, I'm going to,
so in this respect, absolutely. 100%.
Subtitles will shit all over the
delivery of standup love you guys,
JC settled nuance.
You can't do it that
way guys. No. Yeah. Uh,
here's a little game.
You see these guys right here?
My life. So this is a
the piss on me, right?
Beat me or fuck me games is crazy. So
what you're supposed to do here? Yeah,
I got it already,
I think.
I don't know why this is not letting
me do both. At the same time.
Oh for fuck's sake, I'm not going
to play you play. I would rather,
I would uh, have a, would you
rather have source of share it?
This question Rachel originated
on the why each sub reddit.
I thought maybe the main mommy's would
like to weigh in a user myth of 1886
submitted a post titled We'd
Rather Fuck Marry, kill.
And why with these three recent
your mom's house podcast superstars.
However, because fuck marry,
kill is an awful game.
And since you'd have to be homeless,
a thug or just out of jail and considered
marry one of these human scrubs I've
suggested we update the game a bit.
So I would the woods would we rather
I've proposed to you is between the tried
out guy,
the Sissy Fremont Street and shit pig.
Who would you rather
fuck piss on and beat.
I really liked the pain of the water
champ and also Christina on this pressing
record.
Stay glass in Corey.
So you just have to say who do I want
to fuck? Hold on, I want to piss on.
Who do I want to beat the shit out of.
And the three superstars
are the try it out guy,
the Cecilia Fremont and
the Ima shit pig shit bag.
Whenever you want to call them.
That guy pass on me.
Fucking God with this on me.
Beat me or beat.
Yeah it's pass beat or what?
It's pice beat and fuck like
this is terrible. Oh my God. No,
I don't know how much I cool.
Fuck yeah,
I dunno.
Well here's what we know for sure.
The three of them. Oh this is
interesting when you can kind of,
we know for sure that all three
want to be physically assaulted.
This guy says kiss on me,
be me. You know. Yeah.
He's like,
beat the shit out of me.
This guy specifically asked to be beat
the shit out of by white women with
tattoos and actually antagonizes
them. Yes. Hopes of attracting.
He is down with it even though he would
like to choose a certain type and this
six son of a bitch was like, you
can just shit in my mouth. And, uh,
and so we know also that these two outside
guys are down with being pissed on,
which is one of the questions here.
So,
so far the three of them
are done with being beat.
So what I'm saying is you don't have
to feel guilty about beating you one of
them. That's really why I'm
bringing it up first. Yeah.
The three of them are down with it and
this guy wants you to really beat the
shit out of him. Like, um,
the difficult thing here is we know
that the outside two guys here,
the try it out, guy and the shit pig
are also down with being pissed on.
They encourage it. Right. Okay.
This guy is not, and you know,
the hardest decision of this
whole thing is who to fuck.
That's the biggest problem I think you
really have to do is eliminate people.
You know,
I think the greatest thrill would be
from beating the sissy of free months.
I want to hit him the most.
I feel like he antagonizes you,
he wants you to do and he's a bit aloof.
There's a sense of a little bit
of arrogance. He's taunting you.
He's daring you to do it.
And I kind of want to give that guy what
he wants because it's a shit head about
it. I wouldn't mind giving him a
beating. Allowed me to shove him.
I agree with that one then the pissing,
it's like they both,
these two guys both want to, it's
really cool. Can you tolerate fucking
yeah.
Who would you want to fuck the tried
out guy or the dog? Shit Guy. I mean,
I think it'd be more tolerable
to fuck this guy on the end here.
On the right side. Why? Uh,
because I think it could be a house
of horrors with this guy and this guy,
the shift pick guy. It's
a little bit more, um,
like he's just,
he's going to do what you say.
Yeah. He, he seems more together
then try it out. Try it out
guys. Just a mess. Okay.
Here's what we're going to do.
Try it out.
Guy Gets pissed on because he's such a
hot mass. He's totally out of reality.
Yeah.
And then the dog
guy gets fucked. That's what I'm
saying. That's what I'm saying.
However you fucked the dog shit guy.
He's going to,
except he's not pushing back on anything.
Does he want to be fucked?
That's the thing.
I feel like he wants more of abuse then
he might want the piss on me and then
the tried out guy. The trout
guy wants to be fucked, Tom.
That's all he focuses on is, fuck
me. Fuck me. I want to be fucked.
That's the thing. That's all he's asking
for is come over here and fuck me.
At least in a keys offering it for,
you know, everything. Black eyes,
uh, jail. Whoever just fucked me.
I need to get fucked a lot, man.
I'm a shape pay.
Okay.
I've done, I've heard. I need to
know. I've heard about everything.
Here's what we're going to do.
We're going to Piss on that guy.
We're going to piss on that guy
because all he wants his deck,
he sounds like he wants degradation.
He wants to be humiliated.
Fuck the other guy wants to fuck it.
Seems like to me,
you're just giving people
what they want. Well, yeah.
Then it's mutually beneficial,
but this is about what you want and it's
time to stand up for what you want to
do. Right. But I want to do what's going
to be a greater, a better experience.
Do you know what I'm saying?
I want to match up if we're going to
do love who are most turned on by?
How about start there?
Go there and then build out from
that is a hard question to answer.
Who Do you want to make?
All of them are just so tantalizing.
Which one turns you on the most?
I think this,
this would be the most tolerable to
look at up close to this shiny teeth.
Hey, I'll come to you. See, I mean
I could hang out with this guy.
I could definitely, I could get into
being like, hey shit pig. Get over here.
Thank you. Saying shit bag. He's
has a heavy accent shit bag.
I think it might be full peanut.
Yeah.
I would rather hang out
with to try it out guy.
I would just be less because of
the cool shit that he would say.
I would laugh so fucking hard. He's so
whacked out. More predictable. Involved.
Yeah.
That's why he's
more fun to hang. He's a better, hey,
I don't think he's a fun hang that guy.
Just boring. He's like a run of
the mill, you know. Humiliate me.
Try Now guy.
It's a wild card.
Like you're going to see some crazy shit
when you beat the fucking snuck out of
the free month. Sissy without question. He
gets the beating. We're doing that. Yeah.
I don't want to fuck the dog shit guy.
He's too fragile. He seems too fragile.
I think the tryout guy can handle a fuck.
Yeah.
That guy can handle being peed on.
He wants to be peed on and it's going to
be a better experience because he wants
him Google. Google. I don't like
this guy will get the speech
me up any way you want to do it.
You wake coach me anyway. Come on.
Like tramp.
She has to be dominant
and picks me up like
a girl. Oh Geez. Yeah,
so he's definitely into it though.
I don't like he's emergence wise.
If you're looking for a fun experience,
I think he's going to provide it.
He's the most annoying to
me. You know, he's a chef,
which means it would make
sense to beat him. Yeah. Yeah.
He really fucking annoying.
Just still amazed that you want to fuck
the try it out guy because he wants it
so badly.
He's willing to give you a lease
and a key and put himself out there.
So would you do that?
You would do the strap on him as soon.
Cause that's what he wants. What I
have to be, I have to be a black guy.
What I'm saying so you could get a big
black strap on and give it to him and he
can handle it.
He's there.
The other guys too fragile and he would
cry and be Weird but I could pee on that
guy and it would be fine. He would
want that. I'm fucking that guy.
You're fucking the teeth.
Yeah, dog shit. Oh yeah.
And you're pissing on try it out.
Walk me through your logic here.
I just think it'd be easier to be
around a clearly really submissive,
somewhat believably, more stable
guy, which I think should big is,
and I think try it out guy.
I just want to piss on them and take
off and I'm beating sissy to a pulp.
He gets beaten. He's annoying. No, he
gets, he gets knuckle sandwich for sure.
Um, yeah, that's where I guess we agree
to disagree on it. Just so, I mean, uh,
we'd sure love to hear from you guys
on this very important
debate. Yeah. It's, you know,
potato Patato I honestly,
the the dog Shit Piss Shit Guy.
He annoys a shout to me to try it out.
Guy amuses me.
I would want to hang out with them.
Yeah. I wouldn't want hang out with them.
I'm saying voluntarily, but
if I had to, I would be him.
There are to try it out,
try it out.
Musical by Severen from New Zealand
and there's try it out by Jim Kay.
I know what we do here. We've got
to try it out. Try it out. Um,
personally
beat me. Which one do I play? I want
to hear the New Zealand New Zealand,
their accents a lot.
Okay. Um, here it is Jane.
Unless it's something crazy weird or
something, then I'll, uh, if it's,
if it's like super fucked up,
I haven't heard it,
then I'll just stop it and play now, but
okay. If not, this will be signing off.
And uh, thanks for listening. A
lot of hot topic debates today.
A lot of hot topic debates.
It's very,
very heavy and heat it up.
We're going to have a lot of feedback
and I think so too. Um, all right.
Thanks guys.
We'll see you in a week.
Hello
twin.
You can know.
Fuck me.
I need to be
free food free ren and everything else,
man. Here's the deal, man.
Oh,
your friend.
Can
you gotta leave?
Send the king
three men and the ladies in the cave men.
Um, yeah, no, I'm just,
if you see me, you want to
come over today, try it.
Try it out.
If you in my bill
tried
to calm piss on me.
Uh,
so you
just,
me
looking for hardcore
one,
two,
and,
and want to do and wanted
to trash.
Calm down.
Let's fuck.
Why Trash?
Calm down.